next question yeah let's do it okay i
hurt myself significantly throwing a
roundhouse kick
recently abdominal hernia at the site
of an old appendix surgery i trained
mma five days a week sometimes more
multiple times a day
for two years until last week when he
got that injury
but now i can hardly sit in the chair
without pain and surgery is two months
out
and who knows how long recover recovery
will be
before i can train again what i'm asking
is
what should we as martial artists and
men do in times of forced hiatus
and injury what do we do when there's a
quiet
but we miss the storm
well one thing with injuries
injuries are going to come and you cut
wood
you get sawdust you train you're going
to get injured that's what's going to
happen i mean it's just uh that's just
this is the law this is the law of the
land the number one thing to remember
is and this is something that's really
hard when you're super active and you're
super fired up and you're training all
the time
when you get injured and you get
sidelined you feel like it's never gonna
go away
it feels like it's not healing and
you're just like oh man this i'm doomed
so the the injury is gonna go away now
obviously for some guys for some for
some
actual soldiers or warriors that have
been wounded in a permanent way
that's that's different and those guys
what they do is they learn to adapt
you know they learn how are they going
to get through this how they can adapt
their life
how are they going to roll with one leg
how are they going to do pull-ups
with one hand uh jeff real you know
jeffrey al yep
we were doing burpee pull-ups the other
day i was putting the mma classes
through it if you don't know jeffrey al
awesome guy
awesome fighter awesome jiu-jitsu player
he's born without one hand
i had the guys doing burpee pull-ups
black belt by the way
yeah black belch and he had uh he has
like a little hook he can put on there
to do pull-ups
and i guess the thing was falling off
and so he just threw that thing to the
ground and he was just hooking his
his forearm over and then the other hand
was grabbing he's doing pull-ups yeah
i mean if if jeffrey al
can just jump and do we did i don't know
six rounds worth of burpee pull-ups
or five rounds worth of burpee pull-ups
and he crushed it
no one has any excuse so guys that they
get some kind of a permanent injury they
get wounded
something like that happens okay you got
to adapt to it you got to figure out
what you can do
but the injuries the the basic injuries
the daily injuries the
the temporary injuries that is normal
from training
that that's you're gonna get them and so
of course oh you got an injury good
right it's a little injury be thankful
it's not something worse
you know i've i've had you know a blown
out ankle i've
had a torn mcl and you know what do you
do what do you say when you
tear your acl or your mcl you say okay
awesome
it's not my acl it's not my meniscus you
know the the mcl will heat itself
what do you say if it's your if it is
your acl okay great that's one that can
be repaired with surgery
so none of these problems are permanent
right so be thankful you don't have a
permanent injury
and even though it seems like it's gonna
take forever
like homeboy here who's got two months
before he even gets surgery and then how
long is it gonna take
it seems like it's going to take forever
i had neck surgery right
that's a blip on the right i don't even
remember how long it took it was a long
time i mean it took months to heal from
that i don't
remember that what did i do during that
time i did other exercises i figured
other stuff i watched youtube videos i
figured out other moves you know that's
what i did
so i guess youtube wasn't around i was
watching dvds
jiu-jitsu dvds yeah vhs tapes
so what do you do number one stay active
right you know move do
if you if you can't move your body all
work your forearms
strength right squeeze a tennis ball
one of my buddies blew out his knee
what is it the triple threat he did acl
pcl
meniscus boom heel hook right didn't tap
got to tap to the heel hook people got
to tap to it
yeah got caught in hilo didn't tap blew
his blue it all apart
he was in a he had to get him all
reconstructed so he we had a dummy
remember the big dummy we have at the
gym
we had a big one it was 120 pounds and
he would lay on the ground his knee is
in a full his legs and a full straight
brace won't bend at all
he would lay on the ground and and lay
next to this dummy
and he'd just pull it from one side of
himself put it on the ground on the
other side himself
pull it back to the other side back to
the other side back to the other side so
he's getting this motion
of sort of turning on the ground this
massive core strength and when
we when he finally recovered it was
powerful
and you know when he would turn
underneath you said you got some got
some strength there
so you got to figure out what you can do
you know if you can't roll
box if you can't box
lift if you can't lift
stretch and get that flexibility working
in some area that you're not flexible
whatever you're gonna do stay engaged
stay active because i think
i'm definitely a believer in the active
rest you know what i mean
when you just go okay i'm injured so i'm
just going to sit on the couch and watch
tv
no wrong answer run away from that tv
you got to keep moving because that
keeps your blood flowing and it keeps
getting
gets more blood more circulation more
healing goes to this area that's injured
so do that
and if you but you know still you're
still gonna have more time
in your day right so what are you gonna
do i'll tell you what you're gonna do
get a guitar right learn to play guitar
write a book build a website take
pictures learn a language
read more books expand your brain
right expand your mind when your body
needs a little recovery when your body's
injured
make yourself smarter make yourself
better free your mind
and so the bottom line the question was
what does a man do when there's quiet
and i'll tell you what a man does when
there's quiet he takes advantage of it
right so take advantage of it get
smarter
get better in other ways and when the
body comes back
you'll you will be better yeah that's a
good way to
to put it like take advantage of it like
actively because a lot of times like
where the problem comes about i know
this because when i tore my bicep
that's right i meant i went here i was
watching her out yeah yeah i think you
yeah i was wondering i have a picture of
you laying on the ground
yeah that was messed up i think you sent
me a smarmy text too
something like that no that was for
something else but same day though
nonetheless what where the problem comes
when you miss
the story you miss the action is you're
harping on it it's almost like you have
this
hope like oh it'll be soon or maybe
the the doctor said nine months but
maybe i could do it in four kind of
thing
you know just that mindset where you you
kind of
in a way gotta admit to yourself okay
i'm i'm out
right now i can't roll right now i can't
train mma two times a day
five days a week i cannot do that you
gotta admit that so what did you do
did you work on your video editing
skills during that time oh man that was
i think that was before
or so would you do i forget
i don't know but i'll tell you you did
not take it i'll tell you what i didn't
do is
is hard on it yeah you moved on you
figured out what else you can do
yeah exactly right i was always into
working out and stuff so i would do
other stuff like legs and stuff work
your left arm
all right yeah yeah actually my left arm
is still bigger a little bit
nonetheless i think that that's that's a
good little jump start is don't harp on
it don't
um you got to admit to yourself that
you're you're out you're injured right
now
so and then how you said take advantage
of it dang that's good i wish i would
have known that
actively take advantage because there's
so much advantage to be taken yeah
there's all kinds of time you have yeah
man i think about all the time that i
spend in the gym and on the mats i mean
that's a bunch big chunk of time now
like with with reading for example i got
back into reading and
um look i look at it this way
where as far as books go books that
exist
any information in the whole whether
you're interested in it not interested
whether you can understand it or not
all the information of the world is
accessible
yeah right now more than once more than
any time
ever all different angles different
aspects of everything
it's just out there and you have more
time now
take advantage of that actively actively